they're going to be surprises for sure i
mean the the the the most certain
hallmark of collective intelligence is
that they surprise you that's you know
that's that's the most obvious thing but
you hope that you discover the key
surprises during testing that that's
what all the testing is for
uh called the endless forms most
beautiful 2.0 right it's darwin and
darwin had this phrase and he was like
really impressed with the variety of
living things that he saw in the natural
world this is an n of one you know this
this this phylogenetic tree on earth is
an n of one basically we we are going to
be it's a tiny if you if you plot out
the space of of all possible uh bodies
and minds that go with them everything
we know about on earth is like a tiny
little corner of that and there are just
massively different creatures that we
are going to have to deal with never
never mind what happens if we find life
you know exobiological context outside
the planet never might not we're going
to be making aliens like you can't
believe that's that's just that's just
there's no there's no getting around
that so
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
great fun speaking with dr michael levin
principal investigator at tufts
university whose lab studies anatomical
and behavioral decision making at
multiple scales of biological artificial
and hybrid systems in the following
discussion we talk about regeneration
intelligence
and synthetic living machines
so i hope you enjoyed the conversation
as much as i did
so hi mike thank you very much for
joining me today and welcome to the
cheeky science show
thank you yeah it's good to be here well
i'm like super fascinated and excited to
have you on today um because your
research is just fascinating and
i have so many questions possibly more
questions for you than i have had for
any of my other guests previously so i'm
sure we'll cover like a a broad specs
from a very interesting topic today
great yeah let's let's do it so i guess
yeah we'll just jump straight into it
and
the first topic i just kind of want to
explore is this idea of regeneration and
how i guess
you know if we lose a limb or we lose a
finger like from an evolutionary
perspective that might be seen as being
um
kind of an unfit thing to not be able to
regenerate or regrow
different limbs and obviously
um we have like wound repair systems and
different approaches to dealing with i
guess such stressful events such as loss
of a limb
but i guess my first question is
what exactly is regeneration and how
does regeneration fit onto like the tree
of life and
which organisms do you possess
disability
yeah so so i i i'll tell you what i know
about regeneration in general and then
maybe i can i can float an idea for what
i think it really is because i think
it's a little different than um than how
a lot of people think about it
so regeneration is uh sprinkled uh
pretty uh pretty capriciously acro
across the tree of life
uh there are you know oftentimes people
think that some like
so-called simple systems regenerated and
more advanced ones don't it's really not
like that there are there are very
similar species where some of them
regenerate and others don't regenerate
anything so it's kind of it's it's quite
unclear actually why it comes and goes
some species like planaria regenerate
everything um even small pieces will
regenerate an entire worm
some species like um
salamanders they will regenerate uh
appendages eyes uh limbs uh heart uh
portions of the brain um spinal cord
ovaries
uh some mammals do interesting things so
so for example deer regenerate their
antlers so deer will regenerate a
centimeter and a half of new bone per
day when they're growing their antlers
which is like this amazing amount of
bone and vasculature and innervation and
skin
and you know humans of course regenerate
their liver and things like that so
uh yeah regeneration is uh
it's it's it's really unclear uh
why some species regenerate and some
don't i i can i can tell a couple of
interesting stories about it
one thing that people sometimes think is
that the reason that long-lived species
like us don't regenerate is because it
carries a cancer risk right so the idea
would be that uh if your body has access
to some sort of highly plastic
proliferative cell types then you that
you can you know that can that can
increase the odds of cancer during a
long lifetime so that that view when you
think about it from the bottom up in
terms of cell cycle checkpoints and and
genetic damage and things like that
would predict that animals with the best
regenerative ability would have the
highest levels of cancer and in fact the
the reality is the exact opposite
animals that are good regenerators have
very low cancer and there are all kinds
of uh uh examples of normalization where
for a salamander or a planarian that
does get cancer
you induce regeneration and that process
basically clears it up and normalizes
the cells and and you know you're back
to normal so
i think the better way to look at it is
if if if you don't if you if if the body
does not have very strong anatomical
control so the ability for cellular
collectives to know what it is that they
should be building and and to build it
then you are going to be both not very
regenerative and prone to cellular
defections like cancer so i think
and i think what we're really looking at
when we talk about regeneration i don't
think it is
some special capacity that sort of
evolved as an add-on to to help you
survive injury and stuff like that i
think it's it's the consequence of an
incredibly basic fundamental thing of of
um
multicellular life and in fact even
unicellular animals can regenerate which
is uh uh anatomical homeostasis the idea
that you that that you solve problems in
anatomical speemorphic space meaning
that
you start out at one type of
configuration and you're trying to get
to a particular region of anatomical
orpha space which is that that target
morphology for your species whatever
that might be
and living things to being very good
homeostats have all kinds of tricks to
get to where they're going despite
perturbations like mutation like injury
like
uh teradata you know teratogens all of
that
so i think that um regeneration is
actually the basal state and i think
that for example embryonic development
is a kind of regeneration
in that in that what happens from the
perspective of every developmental stage
the prior stage is really a birth defect
and it needs to be fixed so from the
from the perspective of being a gastrula
the blastula is all wrong and so what
will happen is the blast there's a
remodeling event that takes a blastula
and so i have this i have this model
where
uh
there's a there's a there's a stress
driven
um
set of uh set of homeostatic uh
processes which are basically trying to
reduce the delta between what you think
you should what what what the what the
pattern should be which is encoded in a
particular bioelectrical state which we
can talk about by electricity too
and and and that delta you know as soon
as you've you've remodeled yourself and
you've reduced that delta and now you're
a particular stage that bioelectric
pattern has meanwhile moved on so now
you're wrong again and now you have to
remodel again and it sort of basically
pulls you stage by stage through a set
of regenerative events
that uh eventually and eventually every
you know everything sort of
flattens out in in adult and adult
patterning at least for most animals
and so
yeah that's where i think i think
regeneration is very fundamental it's a
it's a basic homeostatic control loop
well yeah that's a really interesting
viewpoint and to kind of just i guess go
a bit further with the idea about how um
there isn't maybe an increased cancer
risk having this regenerative potential
then why is it you know with humans and
other i guess a large organisms do we
see less of a regenerative potential
like it seems like a kind of
look a bad decision but a bad
evolutionary offense to have done
something like that
no so no one knows for sure but i can
tell a story that may or may not make
sense um
of course there are going to be
trade-offs all kinds of trade-offs and
so so think about our ancestors so let's
say you're some sort of a primitive
mouse-like creature running around the
forest right back in the day and
somebody uh bites your leg off
now
unlike a salamander there's a couple of
major differences different the first
difference is that you're in dry air
instead of water so that means that you
are uh not able to drive the ion
currents out of your wound epithelium
that you would when you were if you were
aquatic most good regenerators are
aquatic right and and being in water is
and this is this is one of the reasons
one of our uh regenerative applications
that we work on has has is these
wearable bioreactors that provide an an
aqueous you know david kaplan's group
works with us to make these aqueous
bio um micro environments for the for
the wound because that's very important
the other very important thing is that
um you're gonna try to put weight on it
unlike a salamander which can sort of
hang out buoyantly you somebody bites
your leg off and you develop some some
delicate blastema cells at the wound
you're immediately gonna be crushing
them into the forest floor and putting
weight on it and so i can easily see
between that and the fact that you might
you're going to you might get infected
and you're going to bleed out and and
you know your whole life cycle life
style is much faster than for for
amphibians
um
i can easily see why evolution would
take the trade off and say let's just
scar but we won't get infected we're not
going to spend all that all that energy
trying to re-regenerate something that's
just going to get wrecked and infected
let's just scar and get inflamed scar
hope we don't we don't you know catch a
terrible infection and see if we can you
know
live through this so that's that's
that's the story that i think makes
sense and of course no one knows for
sure
yeah i mean that does kind of make sense
to me as well but you've already brought
up kind of like where i was heading um
in my thought process with the questions
which is this idea about these wearable
um
biosensors these biodomes i believe you
call them um and you've done uh
experiments in particular with frogs
called cynipus where you've amputated
their limbs and you've got them to wear
these biodomes and you can see
regeneration of their limbs
and not only that but also potentially
functional as well
and this paper i believe came out
earlier this year um and i was just
wondering if maybe you could elaborate a
bit more about what these these biodomes
actually are and how they're functioning
yeah yeah um we actually had a couple of
papers on this there was one in in well
there was a there was a an earlier one
uh in 2018 and then and then there was
this one that just came out the idea is
this we we are we are very interested in
uh
morphogenesis as a collective
intelligence so we're interested in not
micromanaging the process and let's say
3d printing a bunch of stem cells into a
very particular structure we're
interested in understanding how the
collective of the cells normally makes
decisions about what it's going to grow
when it's going to grow and so on and so
our strategy
what we think should be possible is if
if these hypotheses are correct what
should be possible is to find high-level
triggers that don't
sort of babysit the process and try to
control everything that needs to happen
to make an organ but actually just shift
the the the the set point for these
cells and then let them do what they do
best which is to reduce error and to
build to the set point so activate that
homeostatic process
so we start so we started looking for
these for these level
uh control control structures and i
could tell you about others that we
found by studying by electricity so we
make eyes and repairing brain defects
and reprogram tumors so we can talk
about that separately but for the leg
thing we basically found uh and this was
this was uh back in 2010 we did we did
uh we published some work showing that
you can induce tail regeneration now
tails are cool because they have spinal
cord and muscle and so on so we showed
that we can induce tail regeneration uh
just by one hour of application of this
specific ionophore so setting setting
the bioelectric state of the wound uh
using a sodium ionophore but just for
one hour triggers all the downstream
cascades all the gene expressions cell
movement the all that stuff so we looked
for the same we used the um
uh the same uh kind of uh we used the
same kind of cocktail and some different
ones and the idea was in order to
trigger it you need really two things
you need an environment to convince
those cells that it's safe to regenerate
right so you need some sort of a very
controlled closed environment that's
almost like amniotic almost like a limb
bud you know um
and that they would be able to signal to
each other and not get washed out in the
in the bath and so on and then and then
you need the payload which is the signal
the drugs that that cause the signal
right the the so the biodome is the
delivery method and it's the environment
but now you need to have some kind of a
drug in there that will activate them
and so we're working on a variety of uh
but by the way i have to i have to do a
disclosure so david kaplan and i are
um co-founders of a company called
morphaceuticals inc so so
morphaceuticals is all about taking what
we've learned in the frog and moving it
into into mammals so we're doing
experiments in mice now and then
hopefully clint you know clinical work
at some point so so every you know i
have to have to do that that disclosure
and there's a commercial interest here
so the idea so so the idea is that um
we david's group created the biodome the
biodome is filled with an aqueous gel
that's made of silk and that gel has
various other drugs that that we put in
there it's put on the amputation wound
for 24 hours just just one day that's it
24 hours
and then you take it off and you don't
touch the animals again and the leg
grows over a year and a half so you get
a year and a half of light right so
there's a few amazing things i think
about about this number one animals that
normally do not regenerate their legs as
adults in fact can be made to regenerate
their legs as adults right that's even
possible it wasn't known before that
that's possible so it's possible number
two uh it's a very modular effect in
other words we didn't intervene with
finely shaped gradients for a year and a
half we did nothing after the first 24
hours the animal did everything okay so
so it's a very it's a trigger it's not
um it's not it's not a micro management
type of situation number three um in
that trigger
uh we didn't even have to
specify what organ we wanted the the the
trigger cocktail is very generic in fact
we've done the exact same thing to make
tails as it was to make i had to make
legs
it's literally a make whatever belongs
here signal it's not make a leg so so
you never get in on a leg amputation you
never get an eye or a tumor or a tail or
you know anything else you always get
what belongs like
so it's a very context sensitive process
we're not forcing the cells we're
communicating to them that they should
make whatever it is that they already
know goes there the last and then the
last kind of amazing thing about it is
that
this cocktail that was the first one we
tried it wasn't cocktail 78 out of like
300 cocktails that we tried we didn't
have i mean originally one of the
limitations of this work is originally i
i foolishly thought that this was going
to be a rapid screening process that we
could use before you know and it's it's
it's it's not rapid by any means and so
we only got to try one cocktail but the
one cocktail we tried was amazing and so
i you know i i don't believe in luck and
so to me that's that that suggests that
it's not that we just happen to have
somehow lucked out onto the best
cocktail in the world
once we optimize this thing we're really
going to see
remarkable outcomes this is just this is
our first guess at it you know this is
just our first step
yeah no that really is quite incredible
and you've just raised a couple of
questions on my head firstly it's like
how soon do you have to intervene after
you've like induced the damage and like
is there like because i guess you have
to
quickly maybe induce the pattern before
you suppress like the the more like
scarring of the tissue
and then secondly what was the rationale
behind the decision of the drugs that
you use
yeah so
uh
i i don't know when is the latest that
you can do it we don't know in older
work in the tale we did investigate this
and we find out that we find out that
even after the tail of wound forms
what in for the frog is the equivalent
of us of a wound of a scar so it's
basically like this thick non-permissive
epithelium
even after that it still works i have a
feeling that in mammals what you would
have to do is you would have to recut so
if somebody had if somebody had a limb
loss 10 years ago and everything's
healed over i think you're gonna have to
reopen the wound then put on
the biodome and then go from there
that's my guess we don't know but that's
that's that's what i think
um
the uh the choice of the choice of drugs
so
in previous work we had done a few
things we had we had uh tested a couple
of bioelectric interventions which are
kind of the thing my lab focuses on
we've also done progesterone the 2018
paper was about progesterone and that
was because the postdoc at the time
celia herrera rincon wanted to
go upstream and try to find something
that triggers
not only the right bioelectrical signal
but various other changes in the animal
that that might be pro-regenerative so
she went with progesterone and it was
and that was shockingly effective right
the new the new cocktail which is even
better has a number of ingredients which
again not specifically by electric this
time now we're doing a bunch of
bioelectric stuff next but this
particular one had things like
you know it had a it had it had uh
neurotrophic factors in it and it had
growth hormone and it had retinoic acid
which is a positional information
molecule for for it for the limb and it
had um
a uh uh kind of a a resolve in the you
know so so so pro pro wound resolution
kind of kind of molecule and so on
so it was kind of a it was kind of mix a
mix of things that we thought would
would convince the cells that it's time
to regenerate as opposed to you know as
opposed to scar and yeah it worked
really well and i mean i can't wait to
to to get to try all the different
improvements that you can imagine right
after the first trial
yeah for sure and i think you already
sort of mentioned it but as you say you
have the bioreactor on for 24 hours and
then it takes like a year for it to
regrade the limb and so in terms of
scalability it's quite hard to maybe i
guess scale up and try different
interventions but i guess given the
remarkable result from your first
approach then that i guess gives a lot
of promise for identifying um
better and better combinations as well
yeah yeah i mean at this point at this
point uh we're in mice now we're doing
it in mice now but i think there's
probably
not
well if i mean if resources were
unlimited there's still frog things to
be done but but but given given how long
that takes and and limited resources
we're just going for mice at this point
um which which also you know which also
take a little bit of time i mean i you
know in the end in terms of clinical
clinical um
uh kind of import look uh a a a
as a five-year-old's arm is very usable
right you can write you can shave you
can you can eat you can do whatever
you're gonna do so if somebody if
somebody in their 20s
loses an arm in an accident somewhere
and you think that okay five to seven
years later you have an arm that you can
you can type and you can do everything
with that's pretty good that's a good
deal even if even if it you know even
even if even if it grows no faster than
a typical arm you know a kid's a kid's
arm is very usable so i think i think in
the end even worse case scenario i think
it'll be fine
yeah for sure and like in terms of i
guess as you mentioned translating it to
humans what kind of like criteria or
like tick list of achievements do we
need to see before we actually start
giving it as a human therapy serve
well there's a lot there's a long road i
mean lots of lots lots and lots of basic
research needs to happen right so i i
don't want to give the idea that we're
sort of ready to start testing it on
humans because we're absolutely not um
fundamentally there's a number of things
i mean a just to show in mammals that we
can deal with all of the things that are
different you know the blood pressure
the the infection risk the more complex
uh you know um inflammatory response the
bigger uh the bigger diameter of the of
the of the of the limb itself you know
all of these things
have to be have to be dealt with um some
things will be easier you know humans
won't be chewing off the the biodome the
way the mice try to do so so
certain you know certain things will be
will be easier but but there's there's a
lot there's a lot that remains still but
you know we're on the way
yeah for sure and one thing that i
think's kind of intriguing about this
approach is as you sort of mentioned
it's the idea that we don't necessarily
need to fully understand the downstream
molecular details of exactly how it's
coordinating it we just have to like
intervene i guess at a higher level and
the reason that i think that's
interesting is because there's a lot of
i guess interest at the moment in terms
of like personalized genomic approaches
to healthcare and
i guess
um this approach at least at first
glance appears to be something that
might be more universal and maybe the
same set of treatments could be applied
more broadly and i guess do you think
that's the case or do you think there
would still be an element of like
personalization uh
to what like the drug combination could
be
there there is there is going to be an
element of personalization only because
uh
in particular with the bioelectric
treatments you're going to want to know
in your particular patient which
channels are expressed in the wound and
that may differ somewhat person to
person we'll find out but but you're
right fundamentally in that this is a
much more generic approach for the
following reason in any control
structure the further up you go
the less you have to worry about the
details because
the whole point of a hierarchical
control structure is that the details
are delegated so
if if you know if you tell seven
different people um you know uh go get
me a coffee they may do it completely
differently but and you don't but the
point is you don't need to
uh specify well you're gonna move your
right foot three inches this way then
you're gonna you don't need to do any of
that because you're dealing with
competent agents that know how to do
certain things and you don't have to
worry about your message is exactly the
same
even though in each person the molecular
details right of what they hear how they
carry it out what what chemicals go
where in their brain when they hear it
those are all different but but you're
up at a higher level and so
it's uh
addressing addressing these kinds of
things at higher levels has lots of
advantages
um
and one one of the advantages is that
by by by
taking advantage of the fact that you're
working with a competent material that
already knows how to do things
you can leave a lot of the details
uh up to the implementation so so you're
not going to
have to worry about which which channels
are open when you're going to set a set
of bioelectric states and
let let the system go from there that
that i think you know that that part is
going to be the same for everybody and
and then and then different very very
different things what will happen
downstream
yeah that makes sense um
and just one kind of last aspect whilst
we're talking about regeneration still
is um i'm contrasting that to the the
more wound healing and scarring approach
is that one of my interests is in i
guess the circadian rhythm and how there
seems to be some differences and i guess
like the downstream processes at
different times of the day and in
particular with wound healing i know
that there is like an emerging area of
research showing that depending on the
time of the day when the wound occurs
like the healing process can occur at
different speeds
and i was just wondering if you've
looked at all into any of the time of
day links with these regenerative
approaches
it's a fascinating question uh you're
right and and even for example now
they're finding that for chemotherapy it
uh it really depends when you get it
because because the cycling of the stem
cells and also the cancer cells is
related to uh the the time of day and so
on uh we don't we don't know very much
about it we're studying it there's a
there's a there's a postdoc in the group
who's studying time time keeping in the
context of a darpa project on on slowing
biological time for injury and stuff
like that and so so she's working on
this but we we don't know much about it
yet still early days okay cool well i
guess i'll look forward to seeing some
of that research imagine uh so i thought
next week should probably talk about
something that we've actually mentioned
a few times already which is this idea
about bioelectricity and so i was just
wondering if you could actually just
explain more generally what is meant by
this concept and how it differs to guess
what i initially studied which is like
biochemistry
yeah um
let's let's think of it this way i i
like to start like this one of the most
amazing parts of the most amazing aspect
of multicellularity is the ability of
cells to work together towards large
scale goals so what i mean by that is uh
if you have a salamander and you cut off
the arm the cells will work together to
rebuild the arm and then they stop how
do they know when to stop when do they
stop they stop when a correct salamander
arm is finished so what you can say is
not not because of magic but because of
cybernetics and and this this idea that
you know we understand now thermostats
and other things it's it's uh there are
certain devices are are able to minimize
error to some specification so what the
cells will do is they will continue to
to remodel and grow and do whatever
until the error the delta between the
current state and the target state is is
as small as possible right and that's
the same thing for regulative
development and the same thing for
metamorphosis and other types of
remodeling and so on
so if you're going to have a system
where
lots of subunits are working together on
a common goal that's much larger than
themselves so no individual cell knows
what a finger is or can measure the
length of the arm right individual
that's too big for an individual cell to
deal with but the collective absolutely
minimizes delta from having the right
number of fingers having an arm of the
right size of the right shape and so on
so if you're going to do that you need
two things uh you need a some mechanism
for coordinating the cells so binding
them together towards common purpose in
some fact some informational structure
and b you need to be able to store the
set point right so the reason your
thermostat works is because somewhere
there's a it stores what the right range
is and when the temperature gets too low
or too high it'll kick it but it'll
it'll take action to try and get back
into that range so the key those kind of
homeostatic processes only work when you
can store a set point now this is
already we've already left the realm of
typical
molecular biology you know sort of
paradigm because normally what you hear
is that well the genes get expressed
they sort of roll forward under rules of
chemistry and and and maybe some
biomechanics and and whatever you get
that's what you get it's emergence right
it's this idea of local simple rules and
then something wondrous emerges out at
the end but it's actually it's actually
not i mean and that's true that does
exist but in addition to that you have
these very interesting feedback loops
that are not just forward emergence they
they solve problems for example
if you have an animal that has too many
cells or too few cells or you intervene
in various ways much of the time it'll
still find some way to make the right
thing and i can tell you with some
amazing examples of this that are that
are just incredibly impressive
so um so so so what is the computational
medium that underlies all this and one
of the things that immediately strikes
people is weird about this way of
thinking about it is how how is a
collection of cells going to bind itself
to have a memory of what it's supposed
to do and cooperate as a kind of
collective intelligence right that just
sounds sounds implausible until you
remember that well we are all collected
you and i are collective intelligences
right we are a bag of neurons and in
some way those neurons work together to
produce a centralized being that has
memories goals preferences and these
kinds of things that don't belong to any
of the individual cells they belong to
the collective so so we already know
that does exist that that whole process
happens between your ears all the time
so now one might ask okay how does that
happen well
it seems that electrical networks seem
to make that possible right that's not
controversial that's what neuroscience
studies
so one can ask the next question which
is okay where did that come from did
brains did brain suddenly like evolved
this trick and it turns out that
all of the
mechanisms but also the algorithms for
doing that are way older than brains
they exist in our unicellular ancestors
they were evolved around the time of
bacterial biofilms and so evolution
noticed very long time ago that
electricity was a great way to store
information to make decisions to
coordinate information across spatial
distances to make computational networks
right bacteria already know this
so uh what we study in my group
is exactly that uh there's this basic
question of what did bodies think about
before
before they had brains they could think
about three-dimensional space so brains
are really good at thinking about clever
behavior in 3d space so controlling your
muscles to move you around in 3d space
and hopefully have some sort of
intelligence you know in the in the
behavior right before that that that's
an evolutionary pivot before that that
whole that exact same system electrical
networks of cells
were used to store information and
navigate through a space but it wasn't
three-dimensional space it was more for
space it was the space of anatomical
configurations so whereas now the
collective intelligence of your neurons
in your brain moves you through 3d space
before that same trick was used to move
the collective intelligence of embryonic
cells through morphospace through
anatomical space and before that it was
used to move individual cells through um
physiological space and before that
probably metabolic space that's most
likely how it went and so so evolution's
just reusing the same amazing trick and
bioelectricity is really great at this
so so basically
almost everything that we know about
neuroscience holds outside of the
nervous system it's not in in fact in
fact none of the one of the reasons why
we've made progress is that the tools of
neuroscience don't distinguish neurons
from non-neural cells they can't tell
the difference they work in every cell
and so that that tells us something very
important about this this distinction we
have between neuroscience and and and
other fields it's it's a man-made
distinction nature doesn't doesn't
support that so
all these other cells what they're doing
is they use the same tricks they have
ion channels so they form a voltage
gradient across the membrane
uh they have gap junctions which are
electrical synapses these are precursors
of modern um
chemical synapses they have
neurotransmitter neurotransmitter
machinery and neurotransmitters move
under the this electromotive force and
so on um
and so uh yeah and so this so this uh uh
what we've been studying is we we
developed tools basically appropriated
tools from from from neuroscience and
applied those tools and concepts
to
ask to read and write this electrical
information in morphogenesis to ask what
does the collective intelligence uh what
does it measure what does it remember
how does it bind together and can we
rewrite it and the answer is yes we can
we actually rewrite this information now
yeah i was extremely interesting and
like
i think you're right i mean you can
really look back and look at bacteria
and i was gonna mention like
mitochondria as well and healthy the
what i learned from teaching the
students is how we have the proton
pumping that drives i guess atp
synthesis
and so i know as well like neural
signaling which is kind of like the
canonical introduction to
electrochemical signaling or electrical
signaling but then um the body and how
you have potassium and sodium moving as
well as calcium i guess and so what are
like the major
um
like i guess components that have this
charge that are moving across the
channels
yeah it depends it depends on the cells
and the tissues and the species but
basically all of the ions chloride
you know
protons uh potassium and sodium all of
these things move across the across the
membrane and they establish a voltage
gradient and it's the it's the spatial
pattern of voltage gradients that is
interpreted by the cells as as
information and it and it almost doesn't
matter in fact most of the cases that we
look at it doesn't matter what ions were
used to get there right and that's
something we do in in all of our papers
is we show you can get the exact same
effect by altering potassium sodium
chloride protons as long as you get the
moving in the right direction so that
you get the voltage change that you
wanted right you have to calculate that
out which how do i what are the
different ways i can get the voltage
change and again it gets back to this
idea that we just talked about about a
high level control so voltage
is a voltage is a macrostate right it's
like it's it's it's you you get to a
certain voltage by many different
combinations of sodium potassium
concentrations so it's not it's not that
oh this particular ion channel gene and
this particular level of sodium is what
caused my morphogenetic event it's the
voltage state that caused your event and
many different microstates are
compatible with that it's like
temperature right it's like you know
boyle's law you're talking about a
boiler you've got you've got this notion
of temperature or pressure and there's
many many different microstates
underneath that but you don't care
because because of to control that that
that you know that that um uh that that
device you
the the operant variable is is
temperature or pressure
i see so okay see so in terms of like
how you would study this in the lab like
what kind of like approaches can you
used to identify
the different voltages and do you feel
like um the tools have improved over the
last decade or so and it's making it
easier to do these kind of experiments
now
yeah yeah the tools uh the tools are
getting better um what we use so so so
here are here are the things we use uh
to read the voltages we use
voltage-sensitive fluorescent dyes there
are there are also genetically encoded
reporters which are improving all the
time people are making these um you know
variants of gfp and other things that
that fluoresce differentially based on
the voltage
um
and then and then of course you have the
dies they're getting better there's
there's tons of room for improvement
though so one of my one of my real goals
is to work with chemists to make better
better dies so that we have better maps
of voltage
one of the reasons that bioelectricity
has lagged for years behind biochemistry
and genetics is that you can you can
kill a cell fix it with alcohol or
formaldehyde take out the the the gene
the genetic take out the genetic
material take out the proteins the rna
and isolate them and study them and
that's great the all the bioelectrics
disappear the moment the cell is dead
right you can't you can't do any of that
you have to study it in a living state
which means that all of this this this
molecular bioelectricity um which which
of course rests on many decades of work
by by uh you know sort of the
forefathers of this field which used
electrodes and other things but but the
molecular bioelectricity um
it it's only possible now that we have
these in vivo these amazing uh you know
fluorescent and other techniques where
you can do this stuff in vivo so so the
key techniques are of course tracking
the voltage but then the other the other
thing you really want is the functional
experiment you want to rewrite the
voltage so the way you do that is so so
really important no electrodes no fields
no waves no magnets no electromagnetic
radiation none of that
what we're doing is
molecular physiology so specifically
opening and closing ion channels and gap
junctions now that might be with
pharmacology it might be by mutating
them it might be by introducing new
channels or knocking down channels or um
using optogenetics for example we could
we we've we've shown that you can use
light gated channels to to control quite
precisely um that's yeah those are those
kind of tools
i see yeah and um you really sort of
mentioned what i was going to ask you
next which is about how
a lot of the iron movement is regulated
by different channel proteins and at
least from what i remember from
undergrads things like i guess gpcr's
although i'm not entirely sure how many
of them are like iron uh channel
regulators but a lot of the membrane
proteins are quite druggable like
they're on the surface they're easier to
target it's free i guess a variety of
different means so i guess that's yeah i
guess that's a good thing for developing
yeah therapeutics
yeah yeah absolutely i mean you can
think of these these ion channels on the
surface of tissues are the interface
that this hardware is exposing to you as
a as a bioengineer or a regenerative
medicine worker to control the system
and luckily yeah some something like i
think i think i read like 20 of all
drugs are ion channel drugs and so it's
a very uh you know a very good way to uh
with with great specificity the thing is
of course that
like with any interface
the
downstream effects of specific
perturbations are complex so you don't
know exactly what's going to happen
until you've understood the electric
circuit and modeled it so you might for
example shut down a particular potassium
channel well there may be seven other
potassium channels that will open and
close in in to compensate for that
because the cell is fighting you on on
on in your attempts to change the
voltage so it's a it's a much different
it isn't like um you know i'm gonna
knock down this transcription factor and
that's it now now it's now it's gone and
now whatever genes it was supposed to
turn on now now they're off it's it
isn't like that it's a it's very much
you know it's interacting with a complex
computational device and giving it
inputs and and the key is which we've
tried to develop is to have
a
a computational model that predicts
what's going to happen and that you can
invert so that you can say okay but i
want this to happen so now which
channels do i open and close
yeah i guess yeah that is really is a
challenge and in terms of like thinking
about
applying it in fevo in terms of the
different cell types and how you have
like stem cells you have cancerous cells
and i guess what i study is semester
cells like i mean i guess i can look at
the gene expression changes and i can
see that there are differences in the
internal expression
and so can you therefore use
like the voltage of a cell to be able to
identify like
for example a senescent cell was that
potentially possible
yeah yeah so so
so what what you what you uh
what you can get and and by the way
tons of physiomic still needs to be done
okay so so we don't so for example
senescent cells i have no idea if
senescent cells have a different profile
than normal cells however what you can
definitely tell
is
uh stem cells embryonic cells and tumor
cells tend to be quite depolarized
terminally differentiated adult normal
you know somatic cells tend to be
hyperpolarized now
that's fine and that can be useful for
example we have a cancer diagnostics
kind of application where you can use
that to look for a signature of
pre-cancer right look for depolarized
cells but i want to be i want to be very
clear in fact in fact so so i have this
beautiful diagram which shows voltage
from you know minus 80 all the way to
zero and it shows all the cancer cells
cluster down here and the stem cells are
down here and the you know normal cells
up here people people love to see that
diagram i've stopped showing it in talks
because because people focus on that and
it sounds like a neat story and it is
but the problem is that's a single cell
story and this is not fun none of this
is fundamentally a single cell
phenomenon so i don't want people to be
thinking about ah
this cell has a particular voltage
therefore it's this type of cell
therefore problem solved all of the big
problems in this field are not about
single cells
having their own voltage it's about
large groups of cells reading the
voltage of themselves and other groups
of cells it's a network phenomenon so
zooming into individual cells i mean
there's certainly applications for that
but i don't think that's fundamentally
what the bioelectric system is about it
isn't about single cell states it's
about anatomical decisions
yeah i see and i guess as kind of on
from that
at least with like neuronal signaling i
guess if you looked at the photoshop
ferries right it gets hyper polarized
and it depolarizes and so it's not just
necessarily about looking at the i guess
the average um voltage but i guess there
might be fluctuations in the the
frequency in which they change or like
like the i don't know the dynamics of
the voltage
yeah i think i think the nervous system
uses uh temporal encoding more than than
other cells do we don't know quite
frankly we haven't really dug deeply
enough into
the temporal uh properties of other
cells but i if from what we know right
now if i had to guess i would say that
the majority of your body tissues use
spatial encoding so spatial differences
in resting potential whereas the brain
really likes uh that kind of spiking
temporal encoding but i'm sure the it
bleeds over in both directions you know
okay that's cool i said kind of keeping
with i guess bioelectricity still um
there was a really cool study that came
from out from your lab that
was with planarians and he put them in
barium solution which i believe is like
a non-specific inhibitor of some iron
channel and what that did was it
prevented them forming their heads or
something and so you left them in the
solution and then over time they
got this ability to actually make their
heads again and i don't know if i
completely bluffed your article but i
was wondering if you could explain that
in a bit more detail
sure sure so okay so so the basic
observation was this you take you you're
absolutely right barium is a
non-specific potassium channel blocker
so you take your worms you put them in a
barium solution and uh overnight their
heads explode i mean their heads
literally it's called head t progression
that has
just because because there are all these
neurons in there and they can't handle
not being able to exchange potassium so
there's massive cytotoxicity the cells
die
so you got this you got this back half
of the worm and
you leave it in the barium
and what you find out is that after a
couple of weeks
they regenerate a new head
perfectly and the new head doesn't care
at all about the barium no problem and
so you ask yourself well how is this
possible how are these heads of now
surviving barium right so we did we did
a very simple-minded experiment and it
was sort of
it it it's clearly not the only thing to
do because no one said that the
difference has to be transcriptional but
the we the tool was there so we did it
we basically just did um next-gen
sequencing and did a transcriptomic
analysis of what makes and just
subtracted like what makes the barium
adapted heads different from normal
heads
yeah
just transcriptionally what makes them
different yeah and uh and what we found
is that there's only a handful of
there's only a handful of genes that
that that enable them to be barium
adapted so now the important thing about
all of this is is is this think think
about this
planaria never see barium in the wild
there's never been evolutionary pressure
to deal with barium so it's complete
because because i don't see barium in
the wild so so it's unlikely
that
they have a an evolved response of
here's what we do when when we're hit
with barium instead think of the problem
that these cells have to solve you have
tens of thousands of genes it's a little
like i always imagined it being in the
middle of a nuclear reactor control room
and the things melting down and you
don't know
what you know you what you don't have
time to do because planarian cells don't
turn over the way bacteria might you
don't have cells you don't have time to
just try combinations you don't have
time for gradient descent or just
randomly flipping with you know genes up
and down
you don't have time for that uh somehow
you have to figure out which of my
transcriptional uh effectors of my my
transcriptional actions that i can take
are going to resolve this completely
novel physiological stressor
that's a really interesting problem
anywhere in any other space we would be
calling it intelligence right if you if
you had a device that was uh
that was designed to to solve certain
kinds of problems and you gave it a
novel problem and then figure out how to
solve it using the tools that it had you
would say well that's a that's a cool
example of intelli i mean that's what
intelligence is right it's using what
you know to solve new problems
um
it's yeah it's an amazing thing and and
we don't really know how it works i mean
i have a i have an idea but but we don't
really know how it works and i think
this is just the tip of the iceberg i
think cells are incredibly good at
dealing with cells and cellular
collectives because of that multi-scale
competency architecture they have a
really um remarkable ability to to deal
with novelty
thank you yeah thank you for explaining
that in a bit more detail and i think as
well in that study um you then put them
back into water
and then back into barium and then they
had lost the ability and so um what does
that tell us about the memory of the
system is the memory expensive and so
maybe as you say they're not used to
bury them then they were like well
i don't know how to explain it but they
were like it's not adaptive to waste
this energy storing some memory of this
offense if it's unlikely to happen again
that's yeah that's entirely possible
that's one way to think about it another
way to think about it is imagine
transcriptional space which is obvious
hi it's it's a very high dimensional
space so it's impossible for us to
visualize it but but imagine
transcriptional space in that space
there's going to be an attractor that is
the standard
um normal planarian way to have your
genes expressed and then there's going
to be another attractor a small one
that's works really well when you've
been challenged by barium so i think
that uh staying in that in that other
attractor is probably you know when
you're challenged you sort of wander
around and find that space and then you
can regrow your head and life is good
but it may be that either it's expensive
as you say energetically expensive or
it's just that dynamically that
attractor is kind of shallow and it's
really easy to sort of fall out of it
and if you fall out of it you probably
go back to the big one right so you can
imagine like this big you know this big
bowl and next to it there's like a
little bowl and you're sitting in the
little bowl and then you know everything
is a little bit shaking and and so
chances are eventually you're gonna
unless there's pressure for you to stay
there you're probably gonna eventually
end up in the big standard tractor so
that's that's another way to think about
that to really understand this is going
to have to wait until um
we're going to we're going to do a
single cell rna-seq and
just track the path of each animal in
through that space to actually find out
how they how you know how they find the
right region of of transcriptional space
okay that's super cool and i think it
was also speaking of memory and
planarians um there was a study you did
as well where you again perhaps the
electrical network and you basically
made the plumerians have two heads and
this time every time they kind of like
i'm not entirely sure how they replicate
actually but um they capped the person
of two heads and stuff like they had
somehow created this memory and do you
have any idea like
you know where is this memory being
stored because the the dna is exactly
the same
yeah yeah we can we can see it it's uh
it's stored it's stored there's an
electrical circuit that um is uh
my it's you can think about it as um as
a piece of uh as a piece of uh ram it's
basically a piece of electrically active
memory you can we can see that we can
literally see the memory with this
voltage die you can see where it says
one head and you can see how to change
it to make it say two heads and when you
do that the cells when they are injured
the cells will consult the memory they
say ah
i guess a good planarian has two heads
and i'll build two heads and that the
the amazing thing about that circuit is
that
it uh it keeps the memory and it also
there's a there's another there's
another tricky part of this which is
which is uh this kind of uh planar
polarity of the cell so there's a
there's a
there's a a feedback between the
bioelectrics which is kind of like the
short-term memory and then cytoskeleton
organization in the cells which which
maybe you can think about as kind of a
longer-term memory so both of those are
affected and uh yeah and and
and as a result
you have these uh you have these tissues
that just persist in this in this
pattern you can set it back we can take
a two headed warm and make you set it
back to one headed but in the meantime
the the memory the memory holds
basically and you can do you can you can
do another interesting trick with it
which is you cut you cut off their heads
and then you um prevent the cells from
communicating electrically so you block
the gap junctions basically with general
anaesthetic it's the same thing that
general anesthesia does
and
when you do that when you then so 48
hours of that you pull them out
and they will regain that electrolyte
electrical network will regain an
attractor
but
it doesn't always find the right one and
so when that happens it lands in a
different one that belongs to a
different species so you will get
planaria with heads that belong to
different species so so instead of the
nice triangular head you'll get flat
ones round ones
ones that belong to other species
including the shape of the brain the
distribution of stem cells everything
becomes like these other species
and uh yeah even though as you say even
though the the genetics is not edited
yeah that's incredible and and so what
does this electrical memory then tell us
about like how
in our brains we record memories does
that provide any insight at all
yeah i think i think i think you're on
to something very important um i do
think that um
understanding how this works is going to
do a lot of good for neuroscience
because in neuroscience there's a
problem you know most people study
memory let's say in synaptic um you know
synaptic structures and synaptic
plasticity that whole story of memories
being stored in synaptic specific
synaptic structures is kind of
unraveling there's a lot of reasons why
that's probably wrong at this point and
um
i think that i think that trying to
understand uh
how
other kinds of memories are stored such
as morphological memories and so on
might actually put us on to the right
thing and i actually suspect and this is
a total um conjecture at this point from
for me but uh i suspect that actually
cytoskeleton is going to be a really key
part of this and my guess is this is
just again
my my own guess is that neural networks
are not there to store memories they're
there to interpret um engrams that are
probably cytoskeletal in in in nature so
i actually think that the the real
medium of storing them is going to be
some some biochemical structure probably
cytoskeleton maybe something else and
what the neural nets do is is interpret
it and reconstruct reconstruct memories
on the fly by reading these these
chemical cues as opposed to trying to
store them
well yeah but that's super fascinating
in fact like i think i maybe did come
across a review article like a euro
sergey that had a similar kind of like
idea so this is definitely something
that i'm like interested in just reading
about them myself anyway so that's super
cool
um i guess like yeah speaking more about
um
memory and just like intelligence in
general um and how like intelligence can
be seen i guess like at different levels
um and how you don't have to have like a
brain and a
multicellularity to have intelligence
because you had an interesting study
that came out a couple of years ago
maybe uh where you have something called
sunnybots but you just took some
some cells and you uh
i mean you're probably going to explain
it better than i can but you were able
to
sort of get it to do different behaviors
and show forms of intelligence and i was
wondering if you could explain a bit
better than i have about that
yeah so so there's two there's two
interesting pieces there um
one one piece it has to do with
intelligence and then and then uh more
broadly and then i'll talk about the
xenobots um i wanna i wanna start with
the intelligence part because i i
haven't specifically made any claims
about
what kind of intelligence the zenobots
have that's still very much under
investigation but i want to i want to
say something about intelligence first
um
to me here's here's a proposed and there
are many but here's a proposed
definition of intelligence and i i
intelligence i think is uh i like
william james's intelligence definition
of intelligence which is the ability to
get to the same goal by different means
so i think that's very powerful and well
i would put two twists on that i would
say one is yes and that goal can be
stated in many different problem spaces
it's not just physical space but it
might be morphospace it might be
transcriptional space it might be um you
know linguistic space in the case of of
advanced humans and whatnot uh
transcript transcriptional space
physiological space and your degree of
intelligence is
the competency with which you pursue the
goals that you pursue and your
sort of cognitive sophistication is the
size of the goals you're able to pursue
literally this the size in that space so
if you can only if if what stresses you
out is being far from your goal of
having the right local sugar
concentration you're probably a
bacterium
if
what if if on the other hand you're able
to pursue a goal about the size of a
human arm you're probably a collection
of cells making an arm if your goal is
um
you know a particular quality of the
earth's financial markets and and you
know peace among men you're probably a
human that you can con you can even work
towards you can represent a goal of that
size right maybe maybe one that's not
going to be done in your lifetime and
that's an amazing thing that humans can
do so so so i have a very uh functional
generic view of intelligence
i don't think it matters what you're
made of how you got here being involved
design i don't think any of that matters
what matters is are you a system that
uh can pursue different types of
different scales of goals and how how
competently do you pursue them to get
caught in local
minima do you have um any kind of uh
delayed gratification so you can go
around boundaries to get where you need
to be that kind of stuff
so the reason that the reason that i
think it's important to do that is
people people often have these binary
categories which i think are completely
false and and really hold back progress
people will say things like
i and maybe some apes and maybe my dog
and maybe an octopus and people fight
about that uh
we are true intelligences this other
stuff well that's just physics that's
just a metaphor i mean i can see the
mechanisms you know the eplysia has this
and that mechanism for you know
habituation and that's just chemistry
and physics i have real intelligence
this is of course uh impossible now that
we we know about evolution and
developmental biology we know that each
of us took a very smooth journey from
being a pile of chemical reactions in an
oocyte in an unfertilized oocyte all the
way up to being a human that's going to
make claims about second order cognition
and your true intelligence whatever else
you've got every step along the way was
nice and smooth it was very slow there
was never a lightning bolt that said
boom today you're you're a cognitive
being yesterday you were you were a pi
you were just physics much like in in
evolution that never happened you can
all you can also start to roll back and
ask yourself whatever it is that you
think you have you know moral
culpability and whatever well how about
your ancestors of two hundred thousand
years ago did they have it how about
four thousand a hundred thousand years
ago right well how about like there's
never a set of parents that were just
you know sort of whatever and then their
offspring bang the offspring is now
cognitive right that never happened so
we have to we have to have this gradual
view of of intelligence and we have to
be able to
recognize intelligence and
unconventional embodiments we're
terrible at that we're we're only good
because all our sense organs point out
we're we're only good at recognizing
intelligence in medium-sized objects
moving at medium speeds in
three-dimensional space then we're good
we can see you know the the monkeys
hiding the you know the thing of waters
and ah that's that's pretty smart and so
okay but but if you had access to your
blood like like if you had in in
if you had conscious awareness of the
the blood chemistry of your body at any
given point and you knew what your what
your liver was doing at any point in
time you would be able to recognize that
that organ as being very intelligent in
physiological space you would just be
able to that would be natural to you if
we had senses like that which we don't
so um
so so so i'm always interested in in
problem solving and intelligence in
weird unfamiliar spaces so now let's get
to the to the xenobot business um much
like
uh
let's just warm up for a second with it
with this with this example um
imagine uh newts newts have uh these
these little kidney tubules that lead
that lead to their kidneys they are
normally made from eight to ten cells in
a if you take a cross section through
the through the tubule eight to ten
cells make this circle and inside
there's a lumen and that's your two bill
right what you can do is you can you can
make polyploid newts that have more and
more ends you know it's four n six and
eight and and as you do that the cell
size gets bigger and bigger
so the first thing that's already
amazing is wait a minute with with with
extra copies of all the genetic material
and you still make a normal newt that's
wild but okay that's one thing that the
the you know uh
the the software can make up for like
additional copies of every of every
piece of information that's amazing gets
better than that
uh the newts are the same size so that
means that fewer and fewer cells have to
be used to make the same tubule because
the cells are bigger right so if you
have something that's made of you know
10 legos and the legos are now bigger
you have to use fewer of them to get the
same thing so that's kind of amazing
we're now this isn't just response to
injury or response to environment
your own parts are changing and you can
make up for that that's amazing the most
amazing part is that if you make the
cells truly gigantic such that only one
cell fits what happens is one cell wraps
around itself
leaving a lumen in the middle
and you get your you get your your
normal sized lumen with a completely
different molecular mechanism so instead
of cell to cell communication that
builds a normal tubule now you have some
sort of i don't know cytoskeletal
bending that that drags a single cell
around in a loop like that so what that
tells you is
incredible problem solving on the part
of this collective intelligence despite
the changes in your very own parts
you can call up different molecular
components
to
serve the same large-scale anatomical
need it's a nice example of top-down
causation actually because it's the it's
the anatomy that drives the molecular
biology in this case
so um so that's just an example of of of
cells you know it's kind of like uh i
often in my in my own head i call it
play the hand you're dealt like whatever
you've got you're going to figure out
some way of making the best of it right
it's an amazing capacity so we wanted to
ask a simple question uh about cells in
terms of their plasticity and in terms
of their um
ability to handle novelty and we said
this imag imagine this you look at an
embryo and you look at the skin and you
say what do these skin cells naturally
want to do what do they naturally do and
you might say well they naturally want
to be this two dimensional layer on the
outside of the animal and keep out the
bacteria it's pretty boring but that's
probably what they naturally want to do
well that's not what they naturally want
to do because
if you take those cells out of that
context
and leave them on their own in a little
pile uh
liberate them from the instructive
interactions with the from the rest of
the of the cells
then you get to find out what they
actually want to do when nobody's
bullying them into being the skin layer
when what they actually want to do is
well they could have done many things
they could have crawled apart from each
other they could have died as some cells
do when they're alone they could have um
made a flat monolayer like a cell
culture instead what they do is they
come together they form this little this
little ball
and this by the way was all was all
joint work with um josh bongard's lab uh
they formed this little ball uh the
little the the cilia these these these
moving hairs that they have on their
surface that you normally they're used
to spread the um the mucus down the the
body of the frog they use those cells to
row the the cilia they use them to row
against the water and that thing starts
moving around on its own so what what
can they do they can do mazes they can
um they can navigate all kinds of all
kinds of shapes they can uh regenerate
damage
they can
the most amazing thing they can do is um
if you if you if you sprinkle a bunch of
loose cells in their environment they
will go around and they will collect
those cells into little piles like like
bulldozers they'll sort of bulldoze them
into little piles guess what those piles
do those piles become the next
generation of xenobots they start
zipping around doing the exact same
thing and on and on it goes that's
kinematic self-replication right um it's
kind of von neumann's dream of a machine
that that builds itself out of loose
parts that it finds in the environment
so the amazing so so again so here's
what i think is amazing about and
there's all kinds of practical
applications of this that we can talk
about but but more interesting than that
i think
is this
there's never been selection to be a
good xenobot
where does the zenobot
body plan and behavior come from because
normally when you look at a creature and
you ask why is it a certain shape a
certain color why does it have behaviors
it's easy you say oh a selection because
it had a certain environment and
everything that didn't fit that
environment is dead so that's why it has
it
there's never been the xenobots there's
never been selection to be a good
xenobot why do these cells know how to
do this where does that come from
so it's it's uh you know one of the one
of the things that we've pushed is this
idea that this is a new
robotics and engineering platform not
only does it tell us something
interesting about the problem solving of
these cells like okay now you're in a
different environment you're missing all
the other cells that you're supposed to
have you can't reproduce in the normal
froggy fashion how are you going to do
it they figure out a new way to do it
so there's all that plasticity basal
cognition is all that but it's also a
new way of bioengineering because unlike
normal engineering where you're working
with passive materials where you have to
micromanage everything you have wood and
and copper and whatever else you have to
make sure that that whatever you want to
happen is going to happen
this isn't like that this is a an
agential material the the cells have
agendas they know how to do things and
they want to do things and the only way
you're going to get this material to do
something different is by providing
appropriate inputs stimuli rewards and
punishments incentives you know
attractors attraction molecules whatever
you're going to give them you're not
micromanaging it you're it's like it's
like um
you know it's like building a tower out
of out of cats instead of bricks it's a
completely different strategy right
instead of instead of putting them where
you want that doesn't work with cats you
have to do rewards and punishments so
that you can you know sort of train them
to do these circus tricks
so
uh
that's you know we we
we create the the first generation of
zenobots by manipulating the signals the
environment that that the cells get they
do the exact same thing to the next
generation the only reason this this
reproduction works is because they're
dealing with an agent material right
this wouldn't work with passive cells
nothing would happen it works because
the cells they're working with already
all want to do this too
and i think the other powerful thing
about this is i think evolution does
exactly the same thing i think evolution
is is was mainly works by providing
because because because the material
that evolution works with is is is
already an agential material it's not
starting from scratch every single time
so so what evolution does is it searches
the space of the signals the rewards the
whatever you have to give these cells to
get them to do certain things like hey
you're going to be in a two-dimensional
layer on the outside of the okay tackle
so i think i think it's in it these
these um these zenobots
aside from all the practical stuff they
provide a new window on on problem
solving and origin of body plans on
evolution
on uh on engineering on the idea that
you know evolution
maybe doesn't build solution doesn't
discover solutions to specific problems
like here's a frog
what does the frog genome actually know
well it knows how to survive as a frog
but apparently it also knows how to be a
zenobot who knows what else it can do so
right so so evolution makes
problem-solving machines it doesn't find
specific solutions
and that
is interesting because it doesn't sit
really well with this traditional
picture of evolution as blind and
short-sighted the idea is normally right
evolution is supposed to always take the
short-term payoff
and it's supposed to be blind and
whatever works now that's what it takes
that's were true if that were true
why do we have these things that are so
good at solving scenarios that never
came up before it's almost you know it i
mean engineers do this because they have
foresight right because you try to make
it a a
you know an autonomous vehicle or a
robot or something that's going to
handle multiple things in the future
evolution's not really supposed to do
that so i think there are many you know
many deep questions here
no for sure like i i
yeah i feel like we can talk all night
about this and it's like fascinating
stuff and so like
yeah i guess um i mean i had some
questions about the intelligence which
you mentioned uh prior to this but i
guess we can stay with the center box
for now and like
yeah i mean i guess in theory then could
you do the same thing with human skin
cells and all different um potential
uh
yeah tissue cells and then
um what are the kind of potential
applications i guess in therapeutics but
beyond that as well with using this new
way of thinking
yeah yeah we're
you know i can't give any details
because it's not peer-reviewed yet and
everything but but i can we we're
definitely doing it with other cell
types it's not anything to do with with
amphibians it's not anything to do with
being an embryo it's a much more it's a
much more generic much more generic
phenomenon um the applications
come in a couple of different flavors
one set of applications is
useful synthetic living machines so
once we get better control and and
people people have already said well why
aren't you you know engineering them and
you can put synthetic biology circuits
in and out of course we can and we're
going to but the first three and there's
a couple more coming the first few
papers about this are all native because
because i don't want to this to be well
well look he put some kind of circuit in
it and now it does xyz and the point the
point is look at what these cells
already know how to do with a wild-type
genome right that's that's the point and
but but then of course after that you
program them so once you start once you
can once you can program them with
various
signals and stimuli and and maybe we put
in some some some circuits and whatnot
by electrics of course um
then you can imagine useful machines you
could imagine them uh you know they're
cleaning up the you know oceans they're
um
uh searching for for rare maybe toxic
molecules they're doing sensing rescue
exploration uh micro sculpting organs
for transplantation you know hydroponics
you can imagine a million different a
million different applications then you
can imagine applications in the body
right so so cleaning up arthritic knee
joints chasing down cancer cells or
bacteria in the in the gut uh you know
fusing retinas back to you know where
they belong all that kind of stuff
down you know someday someday in the
future but i think that that's only the
first level the second level is
can we use these
bots as a discovery platform to learn
the rules of morphogenesis you see one
of the things we're not very good at in
fact we're really bad at is
understanding the scaling of goals so
when you make a collective intelligence
system be it
swarm robotics or a group of cells or
some kind of social or financial
structure whatever it is what is the
collective going to want
what are the goals of a collective
they're not linear functions of the
goals of the pieces that's for sure and
so we're not very good at predicting
those we're not getting good at
recognizing them we're not very good at
predicting them and we're not no good at
controlling them
so can we use these zenobots and those
kind of platforms
as an agential material in which we can
practice this new science of
understanding the scaling of goals and
then and if you can do that
then for example in biomedicine you
could if you could
if we get good at telling the zen about
cells what to do in terms of make a you
know make a you know make a little make
a shape that looks like a little house
or something right just
just generic control over growth and
form then we'll be able to do that in
vivo for birth defects traumatic injury
um aging degenerative disease cancer
having nothing to do with the bots
themselves we'll be able to control what
other cells build that that i think is
is kind of the next level of
applications and and then of course the
third level which is sort of you know
the most the most kind of philosophical
of all is
is is to use them as a platform to
really dissolve a lot of our um
you know a lot a lot of our binary
categories that don't really exist but
but we always thought they did because
of of kind of failure of technology and
imagination we thought that there was a
difference between machine and organism
right people say that every every year
somebody publishes a paper saying living
things are not machines and and and and
you know and so they have these binary
categories that are that just did you
just set up a bunch of pseudo problems
that
are not compatible with the modern uh
capabilities of of biology
yeah there's honestly
super fascinating and i think just to go
on from the applications of like the
sunny box or i guess like other
potential uh tissue type equivalence
um if they are as you say like we don't
fully understand this morphological
space and so if you're putting them in
like for therapeutic cues going into the
body
and then inside the body there's like
different environments and different
places and like
how like would it not older than
like what that sunnybot is doing like i
mean it's maybe going to be adapting to
different in
norfolk environments
like i guess how would you fix it but
which once you've told it to do this how
would you ensure it stays like that and
not start doing something else
well yeah i mean so so that's part of
the testing of course right so so you
have to test it in the environments in
which you hope to deploy it so you would
have to test it and you know let's say
let's say if you do have some sort of in
the body application you would have to
test it in an in vivo model where they
encounter that kind of environment and
make sure that it's doing what you know
what you think it's going to do they're
going to be surprises for sure i mean
the the the the most certain hallmark of
collective intelligence is that they
surprise you that's you know that's
that's the most obvious thing but you
hope that you discover the key surprises
during testing that's what all the
testing is for yeah for sure um and i
guess yeah speaking more about this
collective intelligence like what does
that that mean in terms of the earth
like if
there's intelligence at different levels
and how
you know the i do a lot of infantry
cell culture work and i'm like
technically you know they have
intelligence i mean i can see it when i
passage them they're growing they're
responding to what i
drugs i give them
what is yeah what are the ethical
implications of all of this
there are massive ethical implications
but but they're not quite i think what
people think they are
one thing we can note for sure already
with the majority of us i mean certainly
there are vegans and jains and things
like this but the majority of us in this
society
are perfectly okay
eating highly intelligent animals right
so pigs are very smart we eat pigs cows
you know whatever
so so we already it is already the case
that we don't really
set uh set our rules based on
intelligence a little bit right so so
you can get into more trouble doing
things to mammals than you can to fish
but
we you know the factory farming
worldwide tells us that we're not really
that as as as societies we're not really
very careful about about uh how we make
that judgment so from from that
perspective i think i think there's
there's nothing
there's nothing to be said about frog
skin that you should we should be
talking about
about pigs long before we talk about
frog skin so that that i think that and
people people do get very excited about
the xenobots oh you know you're using
these things and what okay but but start
with the start with the factory farming
first and then we could talk about frog
skin however however they raise a much
bigger point which i think we absolutely
should be thinking about
because because life is so interoperable
meaning that you can make chimeras of
different cells from different species
and cells will live on inorganic
substrates and electrodes and and
everything else
we are inevitably heading
excuse me heading for a future where
every possible combination of
evolved biological materials some sort
of synthetic electronic or some other
kind of
you know engineered thing and software
every possible combination is going to
be explored we already have cyborgs we
already have people that control
wheelchairs and other devices with their
mind people with weird prosthetics those
prosthetics thing get weirder and
weirder somebody's going to you know
decide that instead of controlling their
wheelchair they'd like to control their
vacuum cleaner and maybe they're maybe
their neighbors vacuum cleaner and maybe
some sort of maybe some sort of lunar
you know lander and maybe you want
senses that yeah sure you see light but
maybe you'd also like a sense that
directly gives you a feeling of where
the where the you know this the stock
market is today
we are going to be surrounded by
uh modified organisms so so so hybrids
and cyborgs and and bioengineered
animals and plants
that uh it's gonna you know the the
space of possible beings is incredibly
vast and i i just we
my postdoc and i just wrote a paper i'm
on them
called endless forms most beautiful 2.0
right it's darwin darwin had this phrase
and he was like really impressed with a
variety of living things that he saw in
the natural world this is an n of one
you know this this phylogenetic tree on
earth is an n of one basically we we are
going to be it's a tiny if you if you
plot out the space of of all possible uh
bodies and minds that go with them
everything we know about on earth is
like a tiny little corner of that and
there are just massively different
creatures that we are going to have to
deal with never never mind what happens
if we find life you know exobiological
context outside the planet never mind
that we're going to be making aliens
like you can't believe that's that's
just that's just there's no there's no
getting around that so
that means that um for the first time
uh when you encounter some sort of being
you are not going to be able to use
familiar touchstones to figure out how
to relate to it meaning what did we used
to do right you you you came across
something but you could you could you
could tap it like this and if you heard
a metallic clangy sound you could
conclude many things ah it came off a
factory it's probably pretty boring and
dumb and i'm perfectly within my right
to take this thing apart and remake it
into a toaster on the other hand if you
do this and it's sort of soft and furry
you would say right it was evolved it's
probably you know somewhat clever and
i'm going to get in trouble if i'm not
nice to it and things like that
that's all going to be gone that that
stuff is not going to survive the next
couple of decades in the sense that you
where you
so so where we're going is a place where
what somebody's made of what literally
what materials they're made of whether
it's electronics or or some combination
of you know it's it's 70 human brain
cells 30
uh electronics or or maybe you know they
got 20 electronics 10 some other kind of
weird you know octopus cells or whatever
what somebody's somebody's made of and
how they got here meaning evolved
designed or some combination of the two
is not going to be a good guide to their
cognitive capacity
we will not be able to say well it kind
of looks like a fish we know what we can
do with fish right it's we're going to
be we're going to be surrounded by
things that we have absolutely no clue
based on what they look like now darwin
kind of already started us off on that
and and and that was a major upheaval
people got upset about that but that he
was saying that look there's a smooth
continuum between where we are as humans
and other life forms that are simpler
but there's no we're not in the garden
of eden anymore where you've got a bunch
of animals and you've got a bunch of
humans and they're completely different
and we can make different rules so he he
pointed out a one-dimensional continuum
and people went completely nuts over and
still you know kind of kind of crazy
about it that's going to be nothing
compared to what's coming because
instead of a single dimensional
continuum we are going to have a huge
dimensional space of novel beings
and that means that we have to develop
an ethics that is basically more grown
up than what we have now which is how
did you get here and what are you made
of right and you know what when you say
that when you drag that stuff into the
light you can sort of see how childish
that is right and how how sort of
not deep and sort of you know uh how
conceptually and by the way science
fiction has been dealing with us for
hundreds of years right people that that
story is as old as the hills that you
know this the spaceship lands on your
lawn and this thing trundles out and
sort of hands you a you know a poem
about how happy it is to meet you and
then you're like well it's kind of it's
kind of aluminum looking what do i uh
you know what how do i relate to this
thing and and and and what what can i
really do with it so they've been
dealing with that for a long time but
the engineering and the biology have
gone far ahead actually of most of those
stories i mean this is all reality now
so yeah so i think i think there are
massive ethical challenges but they're
not what people think they are it's not
really about frog skin it's about
recognizing
sentience and figuring out a framework
for which i've taken a stab at by the
way i've um you know obviously i don't
know the answers to this but i've taken
a stab at a part part of it uh a
framework for truly diverse
intelligences that that where you can
actually
think about how to relate to beings
regardless of what they look like or how
they got here
yeah for sure i don't i mean you've
already sort of touched on it but like
so why do you see the the future of the
human species um like i know next 50
hundred years and
i guess as well to kind of wrap up a lot
of things we've spoken about how would
you also foresee the future of like
health care and treatment
yeah um a couple things with respect to
to humans i i somebody asked me once
during during an interview like this
somebody asked me well given that you
think everything is up for for change
you know it's organs and and sensory and
whatever what's a human at that point
right like what really is a human i
think that's an excellent question
because if you ask yourself what is it
really that i value about another human
being
is it their genetics
no they're not really is it how they got
here or well i'm really into the fact
that you're a long process of ev through
you know you came by a long process of
evolution not really is it is it what
your internal organs are made of you
know if your spouse went off and came
back and said oh man i just shed a bunch
of internal organs replaced by machine
learning whatever fine who cares uh
you start asking yourself what is it
really that's essential and i think
i think that uh
my answer would be and and this is this
is based on the um
uh kind of framework that i that i've
developed for for comparing diverse
intelligences it's it's your it's the
scope of the goals that you're capable
of of holding on to so specifically
i would say that a human is a it's a
category what you mean when you say
human you don't mean anything about
genetics or or anatomy or anything like
that what you're really saying is
capacity for a certain degree of moral
concern you are capable fundamentally
capable of being morally concerned about
some number of other beings that's what
it means to be minimally human we all
know we all know what diminished
capacity is right you go to court and
and and somebody did something horrible
and then the and the
the lawyer argues he didn't he's got
diminished capacity he didn't he wasn't
able to kind of care about what's
happening he didn't understand all right
we know what diminished capacity is we
should have an idea of what enhanced
capacity is someday
we will have creatures that are so
cognitively large that they will
literally be able to
care about
massive numbers of individuals the way
we can't right we don't have if you know
we don't have our linear range so if
somebody says
uh something happened to uh to some
something terrible happened to to a
thousand people and then and then they
say no actually it was it was you know
it was 50 000 people you don't feel 50
times worse right about it you feel bad
but you don't feel 50 times worse we
don't have the linear range to
literally care about you know we're
limited in that way someday we may have
some sort of uh you know buddha-like uh
uh cognitive beings that actually can
they have a capacity to care and to them
we are as limited as uh some of the
creatures we know for example you know
dogs and whatnot that you know sure they
care about stuff but like a dog is never
gonna care about what happens in the
next town over three weeks from now they
just can't their their cognitive like
cone is too small for that right so
i think uh that's that's if i had to
define a human that's what i would say
human is a minimal level of of care and
concern for other sentient beings and
and and you know it's it's a you know
it's a minimal it's a minimal bar
uh so what's going to happen i think
that bodies as we know it are going to
go out the window i think humanity in
the future is going to be massively
diverse right depending on where you
live probably off planet in many cases
um and how you live and you you will
choose you know when you get old enough
you sort of say well you know i'd like a
senses that plug me into this and that
and and and you know your your brother
will choose something completely
different and we will all
physically structurally we will be
incredibly diverse the genetics will
become more or less irrelevant
but what still makes us human is that
minimal level of of concern and if that
goes away due to certain changes then
you've become something else and you
know that may be good or bad but it'll
be something else
for healthcare i would say this the
biggest change in healthcare is going to
be
right now
all of
molecular medicine is
about the the hardware it's all about
genomic change protein engineering
pathways right all that kind of stuff
that's where computer science was in the
50s in order to reprogram a computer you
had to physically pull wires right you
had to physically rewire it and then
what what happened well you know why do
we have this
information technology revolution
because
we figured out that you're much better
off programming at the software level if
you're if your hardware is good enough
you can't you can't do that to a you
know mechanical clock but but if your
hardware is good enough
you can do this that's what we're going
to discover in in biology we're in in
biomedicine we're going to be
we're going to be addressing the higher
control levels and instead of
trying to i might my gut feeling is that
that's the reason trying to micromanage
all of this stuff and we could talk for
a long time about why i think that uh
instead of trying to micromanage this
stuff which is what results in side
effects and you know you tweak one thing
and something else you know every every
drug has a long list of horrible side
effects um i think the way to beat all
of that is to stop focusing on
suppressing the symptoms
and try to try to
motivate the system to go to a health
state and that means understanding how
that system traverses its space what
does it want what can it remember how
intelligent is it what are the kinds of
problems it can solve what are the
things it cares about can you train can
we train organs can we train pathways we
we published a paper recently and other
people have too
to show that
gene regulatory networks can have six
different kinds of learning
so instead of instead of rewiring these
things through
through um
uh gene gene editing and gene therapy
we should have we should have ways of
training them and and training them for
health states and it's all the
advantages of trading over
micromanagement that you have when you
you know when you train a rat to do a
trick instead of having to go in there
and run every neuron like like a like a
puppet to get it to do what it wants to
do right much easier to train the thing
so i think i think where where
medicine is is going to go i hope is
towards
understanding the high level control
structures and actually resolving
whatever the problem is as opposed to
trying to
address individual
individual symptoms which is kind of
what we have right most most drugs
except for antibiotics and things like
that most drugs that we have you stop
taking it back where you get they don't
fix anything they do right do you stop
taking you're back where you came from
they don't actually change the system at
all so so i think i think we're going to
get past that
yeah and i think as we've spoken about
we've seen yeah multiple examples now
where it seems like having this high
level um interfering and different
interfering at the high level seems to
and not worrying about the micro
management seems to be like a more
effective um way forward and i think
just kind of one from that obviously i
trained us by chemists looking at the
very lower levels and the molecular
details what kind of advice would you
give for
i guess my viewers who are probably also
fascinated by your your research in
terms of
uh
like having a career in science now what
is the best way to kind of understand
have a broad knowledge in different
disciplines which like inevitably seems
to be required to understand
whatever this higher level is and the
the
the downstream manifestations
and i guess just more generally advice
and having an amazing scientific career
as you've you've definitely demonstrated
um yeah i can i can i can say a couple
things i i mean really i
uh i'm kind of amazed every day that
that i'm here doing these things i i
dreamed about it from the time i was a
kid but i pretty much always i pretty
much always thought that it would
like all through grad school for example
i thought today's the day i get kicked
out like that like i pretty much thought
this is this this was it and i'll go
back to programming and whatever um so
so it's not like i had you know it's not
like i knew uh how to do this from from
the beginnings it was a lot of events
that uh that took place but um i will i
will say this uh
what's really key to remember is that
every that the disciplines are not real
and that and what i mean by that is that
every discipline is pretty sure of
various assumptions and the right ways
to look at things
and
what you have to do is really nail
home the idea that that's just one lens
every department every set of people
with their own journal and their own
funding body and their own conferences
they're all using one lens to look at
things and they love that lens and if
you go there and try to do it in a
different way they'll tell you that
you're nuts and there may be somebody
next door
who's using a different lens to whom
everything you're saying is obvious i
see that that happens to me all the time
i give a talk and different parts of the
talk make people mad depending on what
uh what department i'm in there are
things that i can say in one department
they're like yes so of course and then
in another department were you crazy so
right so so you just have to realize
that you should you you if you really
want to
uh
do new things and i think we're getting
to the point as a society where all the
stuff that could have been done with a
single lens is pretty much done right
we've kind of all the easy things that
could have been solved from a single
perspective i think they're mostly
solved everything that's which is a my
which is a far minority of the things
that need to be solved everything else
needs needs needs needs you to crack out
of that lens and use multiple approaches
that are informed by different ways of
looking at the world so computer
scientists
physicists
uh biologists cognitive scientists at
all levels right uh they all they all
look at the world in a completely
different way and
we just need to i think we need to
commit to all of those may or may not be
useful so just be ready to try them out
and discard them as you will
and get really comfortable with those
with those kinds of lenses so so take
some not not computational biology or
bioinformatics but real honest to god
computer science classes right take an
engineering class where
the most magical class by the way of all
is is is electrical engineering 101
because you start with you start with
ohm's law and like this stupid you know
electrons running through a wire and by
the end of the class you've built a
decision-making device that can follow
an algorithm you make a little computer
that takes instructions off a stack it
does logic it's following an algorithm
you started with physics you ended up
with with logic and and you know in a
thing that that that reads information
and follows instructions and you did it
with your own hand so you know there
wasn't any magic
it's like incredible right
so so those kinds of ways to to think
about things you know or or physicists
you know um
and the way that the way that they like
to have explanations you know
f equals m a right that kind of
explanation would never fly in a
molecular biology class they they hate
that kind of stuff but but for a
physicist that's a great that's a great
explanation so uh
computer science especially right and
and their emphasis on um
um multiple realizability and the fact
that that that the algorithm is the key
and it doesn't matter if you're made of
you know of of silicon and and you know
electron flows or like dandenon says
beer cans and string it doesn't matter
so so all of those perspectives so so
that's what that's what i that's what i
think i think it's really important to
just
realize that everything you've been
taught by a certain set of people is is
all from one perspective and that things
that they believe
are
are are you know sort of sacred like all
your explanations should be at the level
of chemistry right that's i mean what is
what is that's not even that's not even
reductionism or if you're a real
reductionist you'd want to do it in
terms of quantum foam but you don't want
to do that you want chemistry so so
right so so every field has these these
things that they hold on to
and i think i think uh we're we're
rapidly getting to the place where
progress means you gotta you gotta try
on some new some new lenses
yeah sure though that's incredible
advice and obviously having read a lot
of your research it really has like
introduced me to a lot of concepts that
i've never heard of before and like it
now as you say it makes me think about
things differently because i've been
like say trained i mean i don't want to
say anything bad about my education but
like you do doesn't
um
you do put these lenses on how you think
about a certain subject and i think it
is important to
yeah have that sort of diverse
understanding so um we've had an
absolutely incredible conversation and
so um where can my viewers go to find
out more about your lab research or to
um yeah find out about yeah more what
you're doing
yeah um everything is at
this is at a website drmik11.org
so there there's links to the various
institutes so like the icdo our
institute for computer designed
organisms which is all the zen about
stuff all the papers all the primary
papers a bunch of talks that i've given
um
everything is there it's pretty it's
pretty up to date all the papers all the
you know everything is there lots of
material so oh and i also have a twitter
feed a twitter feed at drmik11
i just what i have to say is excellent
to follow um yeah as i can see in the
background an amazing uh
you have collection of books which as
well i would love to be able to read
them all at some point but yeah um me
too me too it's time to read it's time
to re it's time to re-read i mean many
of these i read 30 40 years ago and i
you know you you look at them you say
wow i wonder if i would squeeze
something completely different out of it
now so
and if i for sure i mean i was actually
just reading a paper um this one that's
relevant to my phd work
for the first time in like two years and
even just two years i've now thought
something very different from it than i
did the first time so yeah like
anyway i gotta start said thank you so
much for uh yeah taking the time to
speak with me today and i was the best
best of luck for your research and i
look forward to seeing your latest
discoveries likewise yeah thanks so much
good luck with everything keep in touch
yeah be in touch
you